mobile games it is a dominating Market
in the video game space with Millions
upon millions of people playing them
every single day
and I'm not one of them because I've
never given mobile games a fair chance
but
that is about the change
the mobile market is a never-ending sea
of games with thousands of apps being
added every single week and just
thinking of where to begin can be well
daunting to say the least personally
I've always tried to keep a healthy
relationship with my phone and playing
games on it was always one of the places
where I drew a line but I also know I'm
probably missing out on some great ones
including quite possibly my next
favorite game so this is seven days of
only playing mobile games
okay first things first here are my
boundaries for the next week one no game
streaming or cloud services so that does
that means I can't use Game Pass OR
stream something from a console to my
phone off limits two no backbone or
accessory so this means I can't use any
external controllers for now three no
consoles this may not seem like a big
deal but I play these things every
single day especially my 3DS there's a
reason why it lives right next to my bed
and there's also a few games that
started that haven't finished on it it's
only seven days it's only a week but
this is what I was gonna put the
consoles in why are you trying to stop
this this way I have zero temptation
it's for the best
and four just my iPhone and the intent
behind this is basically to view this as
my soul game console which is
already kind of hard to wrap my head
around because
I'm not actually sure what iPhone this
is I mostly just usually take very
flattering pictures of myself so
no but seriously what what iPhone is
this
and so
we begin
[Music]
I opened the App Store and I was
paralyzed with options especially with
no basis on what to even start with top
on My Talking Tom plus raise your your
own feline friend
of course I was familiar with short form
games like Clash of Clans or Angry Birds
but that wasn't necessarily what I was
looking for in fact I didn't actually
even know what I was looking for one
thing was for sure is that I knew the
big game stuff like ancient impact Call
of Duty Diablo Immortal I've heard of
that I'll just get the big one I'll get
the big ones I made a character jumped
in and already holding my phone
horizontally and using touch screen
controls would be something I'd have to
get used to among a few other things oh
God I have messages already interrupting
my gameplay God
you guys do not disturb
it was fine but I'd be lying if I said I
was a big Diablo fan to begin with so it
didn't take long until I began aimlessly
downloading things only to play them for
a moment lose interest quickly or hit a
paywall and then delete them nearly as
fast as I downloaded them no shame to
those games but I needed Kirk game
something with a story a Direction so
I searched story
and that took me to an insightful corner
of this Market surging's story revealed
a bustling array of romantic visual
novels and um
yeah I download them
the best part though is that the sexy
options cost in-game currency and the
most boring options are completely free
it was honestly a great way to end day
one into play while I was falling asleep
[Music]
all right we're in day two and I already
have some good stuff that's also very
eagerly applied with some annoying bad
stuff on a positive note while I was
uploading footage to my computer at work
instead of just Doom scrolling on
Twitter I was like you know what I want
to pop my phone up I'm gonna play hidden
object game that sounds like fun until
five minutes later and then I was forced
to watch what felt like a two minute ad
and that's when I realized I'm getting
sick of free real quick in trying to use
my phone as a distraction from something
I ended up having to try and find a
distraction because of the ads from the
distraction I wanted in the first place
I still didn't open Twitter though so
that's a good sign but if I'm really
gonna start actually trying to look at
this thing as a console and I don't want
to deal with a constant distraction the
constant spoon feeding of advertisements
and I have to buy games
yeah so I open my phone again to the Sea
of apps but this time I wasn't just here
to Window Shop I was invested in one
game in particular stood out to me and
just like that something marvelous had
happened
[Music]
this is an interesting one because Kurt
you're playing a bunch of mobile games
yes for video yes probably don't want to
talk too much about them or do you I
mean I I would I will actually there's
maybe there's maybe one or two like I'm
willing to talk about in my journey to
find uh things I'm enjoying I started
playing Florence oh okay that's really I
was gonna ask if you would check that
one out because that is the mobile game
overnight it seemed to have taken my
attention away from the world around me
instead of scrolling endlessly through
social media on my lunch break I was
peeling back the layers of Florence's
story when I'd usually be watching trash
TV about alien conspiracies I was
organizing a new chapter of her life by
day four having already finished
Florence it had felt as though I had an
Awakening moment up until playing
Florence which I just kind of bought on
a whim I was only playing free games but
there was something about them even
Diablo Immortal that just felt small
like that they were only meant in small
doses and because of that they were
serving a very specific thing this thing
the fill time and between other small
things a distraction in between
distractions but Florence was the exact
experience I was looking for I was
looking for something that felt as
though it was using this device with a
sense of intent as though its design
choices were deliberate stuff like
scrolling to see the panels that are
telling the stories the next switches
over to you doing math problems and then
it switches over to you tapping on notes
which requires you to turn the phone to
see how the scene unravels in a certain
way and it's just it's beautiful like
it's that's exactly the experience I was
looking for and just like that I started
to view the once overwhelming Market of
mobile games a little differently I
would suggested games like bury me my
love a text message Adventure that
unraveled entirely in a choose your
response style conversation an
experience that was paced as though I
was really texting someone I got device
six a game that quite literally churns
the use of the phone on its head
and the list of what to play next just
kept growing
I thought for so long that mobile games
were these things designed to induce
quick serotonin hits to keep me hooked
on simple and addictive gameplay
mechanics but what ended up happening
was the absolute opposite the games that
kept me coming back were games like
Florence bear me my love device six
games that use the phone in
unconventional and creative ways to tell
engaging and often times moving stories
[Music]
completed Florence I just completed
device six last night I'm still allowing
messages from Barry my love to distract
me and
I signed up for Apple arcade
I think I'm in
my list of games continued to grow The
Artful imagine of narrative game songs
of Bloom chill puzzlers like pattern and
part novel part interactive movie pry
and before I knew it this seven day
trial of only playing mobile games had
come to an end
[Music]
seven days may not have seemed like a
lot but considering that I play these
consoles every single day sometimes old
games for leisure and new ones for work
it was tough but I had to be forced out
of my comfort zone in order to see this
corner of games otherwise it would have
just been like day one where I just
download the first things I see lose
interest and go to play something else
that I'm actually interested in
now having done the whole thing my
biggest takeaway was just how shallow My
Lens was into the mobile market because
like I said I knew the big ones I knew
the pubgs the Kenshin impacts the candy
crushes and the grindstones and those
are totally absolutely completely fine
but me only seeing that was an absolute
disservice to the Sea of incredibly
interesting remarkable games that I
found and by the end to my surprise I
didn't just manage the fine games that I
loved but I found things that completely
warped my perception of this thing I
played games that should only be
experienced on a phone now
with all that said if you'll excuse me I
have a romantic visual novel called
waking up pregnant that I need to
attempt
[Music]